chapter 8 looking back from a higher
level as I look back on my experiences
it's interesting to reflect on how my
perspectives have changed when I started
out each and every twist and turn I
encountered whether in the markets or in
my life in general
looked really big and dramatic up close
like unique life-or-death experiences
that were coming at me fast with time
and experience I came to see each
encounter as another one of those that I
could approach more calmly and
analytically like a biologist might
approach an encounter with a threatening
creature in the jungle first by
identifying its species and then drawing
on his prior knowledge about its
expected behaviors and reacting
appropriately when I was faced with the
types of situations I had encountered
before I drew on the principles I had
learned for dealing with them but when I
ran into new ones I hadn't seen before I
would be painfully surprised by studying
all those painful first-time encounters
I learned that even if they hadn't
happened to me most of them had happened
to other people and other times in
places which gave me a healthy respect
for history a hunger to have a universal
understanding of how reality works and
the desire to build timeless and
universal principles for dealing with it
watching the same things happen again
and again I began to see reality as a
gorgeous perpetual motion machine in
which causes become effects that become
causes of new effects and so on I
realized that reality was if not perfect
at least what we are given to deal with
so that any problems or frustrations I
had with it were more productively
directed to dealing with them
effectively than complaining about them
I came to understand that my encounters
were tests of my character and
creativity over time I came to
appreciate what a tiny and short-lived
part of that remarkable system I am and
how it
both good for me and good for the system
for me to know how to interact with it
well in gaining this perspective I began
to experience painful moments in a
radically different way instead of
feeling frustrated or overwhelmed
I saw pain as nature's reminder that
there is something important for me to
learn encountering pains and figuring
out the lessons they were trying to give
me became sort of a game for me the more
I played it the better I got at it the
less painful those situations became and
the more rewarding the process of
reflecting developing principles and
then getting rewards for using those
principles became I learned to love my
struggles which I suppose is a healthy
perspective to have like learning to
love exercising which by the way I
haven't managed yet to do in my early
years I looked up to extraordinarily
successful people thinking that they
were successful because they were
extraordinary after I got to know such
people personally I realized that all of
them like me like everyone make mistakes
struggle with their weaknesses and don't
feel that they are particularly special
or great they are no happier than the
rest of us and they struggle just as
much or more than average folks even
after they surpassed their wildest
dreams
they still experience more struggle than
glory this has certainly been true for
me while I surpassed my wildest dreams
decades ago I'm still struggling today
in time I realized that the satisfaction
of success doesn't come from achieving
your goals but from struggling well to
understand what I mean imagine your
greatest goal whatever it is making a
ton of money winning an Academy Award
running a great organization being great
at a sport now imagine instantaneously
achieving it you'd be happy at first but
not for long
you would soon find yourself needing
something else
struggle for just look at people who
obtain their dreams early the early
childhood star the lottery winner the
professional athlete who Peaks early
they typically don't end up happy unless
they get excited about something else
bigger and better to struggle for since
life brings us both ups and downs
struggling well doesn't just make your
ups better it makes your downs less bad
I'm still struggling and I will until I
die because even if I try to avoid the
struggles they will find me thanks to
all that struggling and learning I have
done everything I wanted to do gone
everywhere I wanted to go met whomever I
wanted to meet gotten everything I
wanted to own and had a career that has
been enthralling and most rewarding Lee
had many wonderful relationships I have
experienced the full range from having
nothing to having an enormous amount
from being a nobody to being a somebody
so I know the differences while I
experienced them going from the bottom
up rather than the top down which is
preferable and probably influenced my
perspective my assessment is that the
incremental benefits of having a lot and
being on top are not nearly as great as
most people think having the basics a
good bed to sleep in good relationships
good food and good sex is most important
and those things don't get much better
when you have a lot of money or much
worse when you have less and the people
one meets at the top aren't necessarily
more special than those that one meets
at the bottom or in between the marginal
benefits of having more fall off pretty
quickly in fact having a lot more is
worse than having a moderate amount more
because it comes with heavy burdens
being on top gives you a wider range of
options but it also requires more of you
being well known is probably worse than
being anonymous all things considered
and while the beneficial impact
one could have on others is great when
you put it in perspective it's still
infinitesimally small for those reasons
I can't say that having an intense life
filled with accomplishments is better
than having a relaxed life filled with
savoring though I can say being strong
is better than being weak and that
struggling gives one's strength my
nature being what it is I would not have
changed my life but I can't tell you
what's best for you that is for you to
choose what I've seen is that the
happiest people discover their own
nature and match their life to it now
that my desire to succeed has given way
to a desire to help others succeed
that's my current struggle it's now
clear to me that my purpose your purpose
and the purpose of everything is to
evolve and contribute to evolution in
some small way I didn't think about that
at the start I just went after the
things I wanted but along the way I
evolved and I am now sharing these
principles with you to help you evolve I
realized that passing on knowledge is
like passing on DNA it is more important
than the individual because it lives
beyond the individuals life this is my
attempt to help you succeed by passing
along to you what I learned about how to
struggle well or at the very least to
help you get the most out of each unit
of effort you put in